okay thank you for speaking to Sky News
I'd like to start by asking you how
serious you think that this crisis is
for FIFA it's terribly serious and I
think that we have a crucial election
coming up in February I think the
worldwide there is a there is an impetus
to make sure and guarantee that we have
a real leadership to take us through the
next few years and I think that if we
don't get it right it will be a
tremendous problem and I think most
importantly we have to do it for the
sake of football worldwide the most
popular sport in the world as well as
foreign national associations to feel
confident and to know that they have a
real credible ethical and responsible
leadership so why are you the man to be
that leader well I love football I've
dedicated my whole life to the sport and
I believe that it is so powerful both on
the professional as well as the amateur
side for our boys and girls and
therefore i'm determined to fight to
make sure that we have a real
responsible service organization in fifa
you tell you lovable many people love
football this is much more than whether
people like for this is about trust can
you be trusted to reform this
organisation for sure I've been stable
and straightforward and what I think is
needed for them from for the
organization I come from a national
association that understands the
development of football as well as the
fact that i was elected to the FIFA
Executive Committee for four years and I
was there to fight for new ideas a new
way of thinking and in terms of having
an organization that works in the 21st
century and has good practice and
because of that I couldn't remain there
after what I die what I'd seen and I
chose instead to fight for the
leadership of football she's mad likely
you stepped away from the executive
committee because because of what what
what did you see that made you feel you
couldn't
well it's it was the culture itself a
secretive organization I could feel that
that is not the way that the one runs an
organization like like fifa I felt also
that there was almost this impression
that fee for Owens football whereas in
reality it's our national associations
that own FIFA that there is so much more
that can be done in terms of development
of the sport which is the basis of what
FIFA is it is the umbrella for the whole
world and most importantly to have a
real open open organization where
everybody wants to know what's happening
in there and I feel that that's that's
that's what I want to deliver you want
executive committee's you say people
look at this field of candidates and
your rivals and they see fever insiders
current former exco members officials
from the fee for UEFA what makes you
different mind you just another one of
these people who's going to serve
themselves rather than football well
like again i come from a national
association so i take the perspective of
our players or our clubs of our teams
and of the challenges that that need to
be done within the organization I come
from the bottom and we need to reverse
the pyramid and have that be the
priority at the top so that's what my
experience was within the organization
and also it is a matter of leadership as
well that is really key a leadership
that again is responsible in other words
that doesn't pass the blame onto others
and that can give the confidence back to
all our stakeholders be there the
sponsors even the countries that they
live in and to bring back a situation
where people are proud to wear the FIFA
badge again it's very serious criminal
situation that thing finds itself in
investigated by the FBI and the Swiss
the US authorities would you support and
will you cooperate if your fifa
president with the with the US and the
swiss authorities the important thing is
is for the worldwide for everybody to
know that we are serious about making
the real steps in terms of the
organization itself once you do that
then i can approach
all the authorities and say look this is
what we're doing give us a chance were
on the right track and we can now get
back to focusing on what football is
about the development of the sport and
full confidence in how the organization
is run you were on the executive
committee in a period that is the
subject of these inquiries have you had
any contact with the FBI the US
authorities or the Swiss authorities no
I have not they've not spoken to you you
know minakshi I came in to see if I was
elected specifically because from our
continent they wanted a new face in
terms of the organization in Asia I was
the first to support the evaluation of
our of our Confederation and I think
that was that's a very crucial way of
dealing with things in the future but I
was not part of the issues that happen
before be it the bidding process and
what have you but I'm determined to
guarantee that we do things ethically
improperly in the future over Christmas
was it for Christmas mr. Blatter and mr.
Platini both men you know well would ban
what did you think of that eight-year
van they received for this payment well
again that's that's a matter for for for
the Ethics Committee and I'm not focused
on what happened in the past I'm there
to energize the future of the
organization you must have some work in
a real way let's have a view these are
too much senior men in football passing
a more than a million dollars around on
a verbal agreement you must have a view
of that my view is that FIFA again has
to be a proper open organization we have
that full disclosure of finances even
myself I don't know what the real
reality is of the financial structure
within the organization and I'm
determined to make sure that that is
public including salaries for the
president for executive committee
members that's a normal standard for
good practice in any organization
worldwide and going back again I think
there needs to be a cultural change and
I'm starring about you with you saying
we expressing a clear view about what
looks to be a payment was certainly
unethical and surprise you you can't at
least give an opinion and what you think
of the
this verbal contract and passing around
millions of dollars I think it's rather
obvious isn't it I mean that is not how
things are done and good practice around
the world I knew have we have to ensure
that that is the case in the future mr.
Blatter says he's innocent and he's
going to keep fighting on do you think
he's right to fight on everybody has the
right to do what they will but I think
what the responsible thing for the
future of the organization and I think
the desire of member associations around
the world is to have a responsible
leadership for the future and to feel
proud and feel secure in what's
happening with football worldwide and
that includes not only our member
associations where every boy a young
girl who who plays and loves the sport
mr. Blatter told me before Christmas
that he's done nothing wrong and he's
going to fight and fight and fight he
deluded I'm not going to comment on any
other person but I think again it is a
matter of a cultural change I know my
ethics and what they are and that's what
I want to implement in the future you'll
meet the Football Association and the
other nations while you're here in the
UK do you think they'll support you what
can you do to win this but I think it is
it is crucial to get the support of the
home nations and of the FA you know
football in in the UK is so important
for the whole world everybody follows
the Premier League for example and also
on a moral ground I think the UK has
always taken the right Stan an ethical
manner I had the support the last time
around and I'm definitely seeking to get
it again are you confident you get it
because they are I think for the time
being they're holding their counsel you
confident you can persuade well I hope
and I am in contact with them and I
think you know obviously trying to prove
to them that my manifesto is the right
way that the vision is the right thing
for football and I'm pretty optimistic
that we will get their support as you
come around the world meeting national
federation associations have you had a
positive support you confident you're
winning yes
I think that national associations
across the world do want a proper change
they know that I've been consistent the
whole the whole way through and I think
that they want to see a change
themselves there's so many generations
of people in the footballing world who
do want to be proud of this organization
and not have have the name tainted and
so I think that the momentum is there
and we I want to see it through three of
you rivals would appear to have the
support of continental blocks Shaikh
Salman president the AFC Gianni
Infantino from his position at UEFA
perhaps Tokyo's Wally in Africa is this
is there a danger this becomes another
political stitcher what I intend to make
sure that that hopefully that's not
that's not the case in the future
because FIFA is the umbrella for all and
therefore every one of the 209 members
has the right to choose the president
that they deserve and I'm about unity
and I'm tired of seeing the idea of
divisions and people being played off
against each other that has got to end
this is about football it's about
developing the sport globally and it's
about being responsible on how to
approach do you think the people who are
supporting you do you think they in some
ways afraid to say so because of this
climate of big continental politic there
has always been a sort of climate of
intimidation or fear in the past but I
think that even for myself proving that
I come from a small country like Jordan
and development and challenging for the
top of the leadership when I come came
to running against President Blatter
that we all have the right to do what's
what's best for football and we
shouldn't be afraid do you think there
is there still a climate of fear this
time around I think generally from from
meeting with the national associations
across the world the real fear is that
we don't get it right in a selection of
februari you haven't said who's
nominated you I'll ask you if you will
tell us who's nominated you can you can
you tell well I think to be honest the
majority of my nominations came from my
own Confederation
major but again I don't want to get into
interne mming national associations I
think it's their right to decide if they
want to do so publicly I understand that
and your rivals have I don't think have
been transparent about who's back in a
mother does that tell you does that tell
us should that tell the world that
people are still afraid well again it is
up to each National Association to say
who they are and I think the most
important thing is is the actual
election itself and that's what I'm
focused on I think we have to look to
the future even about how things are
done in terms of nominations and and
sometimes I it is recognized that there
is trouble for for for for candidates to
even get nominations in the first place
but again the real answer will come on
the day of the elections themselves just
a couple of points that you've talked
about the past the Garcia report
investigation into World Cup bidding
should it be published and want you to
be published well I was the first two to
demand that the Garcia the report be
published when it happened I think that
it's it's rather ridiculous that we have
asked somebody to come in and do a real
thorough investigation of what happened
on such a critical matter such as the
bidding process and not make it public
and I think again I think we have to
have it published right now not waiting
to put after the elections because as a
candidate we need to know what what's
what's what's happened within the
organization itself if there's something
in there about the water russia or
guitar as FIFA president would you
address that would you consider
reopening those two world cup of bidding
processes at the point is to look and
see what what happened in itself I'm
focused on the future when it comes to
to to to the World Cups and how those
bids are conducted so that they are
clear proper and there's no
mismanagement within within the awarding
of future World Cups regarding otter or
Russia I mean unless there is clear
proof of criminal activity then I
believe obviously they have the right
have you seen anything that's been
published in the media or has been
established by what we have seen
publicly that gives you any concerns
about patio or Russia I have not seen
anything myself and I think that's
exactly why we have to have the
publication of the Garcia report the
oven even with the levels of allegations
around Qatar the your your former
colleague Mohammed bin hammam and the
vast amounts of money that were being
moved around that really doesn't give
you cause the concern about the
credibility of that world cup project
well we've been looking at from what
we're seeing in the media problems with
World Cups going before so there's a
whole system and I think a culture that
needs to be changed at least for the
future and to guarantee that there is a
real proper process for for the World
Cup I mean you you have to have an
investigative team who goes to bidding
nations and make sure that when they
present their findings to the Congress
that it is done based upon the best
recommendations you're as you talk about
changing the way they're awarded in
future there's FIFA president if you do
two terms you'll be attending these two
World Cups can you do you think you can
do so and do so credibly and have the
world have faith that these tournaments
are credible yes I mean I definitely
i'll make sure that that is the case i
think that we have to have the basic
norms of human rights for example of
workers rights and i know that for
example with butter they have said the
right thing but i would be a president
who will make sure that they are dead
they implement them look at your
manifesto one pledge you have in there
is to increase the distribution of funds
to national associations from a quarter
of a million dollars to a million
dollars each that on looked at one way
people will see that's probably the
right use of FIFA's riches on the other
hand people might ask is this not the
same method of patronage that Blatter
used for years to effectively by the
support of small nations I use that word
advisedly no on the contrary I think
that I have looked
what we can see of the budget right now
and it makes sense to give a baseline to
national associations to develop coming
from Jordan for example we need that to
help with the development football and I
have seen for example a haphazard way in
which in which that aid has been given
for example in the last election cycle
it was increased three times to over a
million dollars ironically that's but I
think the important point is to have the
baseline and have it known over a
four-year cycle so that it is not used
or abused according to 22 election in
our periods just about your own
background please them except the
question in which the Spirit is asked
people won't perform people want change
they see an elitist fifa with people
hoarding money themselves you come from
a privileged background a royal
background do you think in some parts of
the world people might wonder whether
that disqualifies you from being a man
who can really reform and there's no
royalty in football first of all and
I've worked very hard with our national
association for example and and with
football and and and and my continent
and I've tried my best in FIFA and I
think again it's a matter of character I
have my own background both in crisis
management for example which is maybe
something that's needed in FIFA at the
moment as well as as my own ethical
background and morals which I take for
my family heritage and I think that in
this time that is crucial for what FIFA
needs in a leader these new rivals have
sufficiently good character I'm not
going to comment on any of my rivals I
am there talking to our national
associations and convincing them that
I'm the right man for the job dita you
can convince enough of them do you think
you can win I think that there is across
the world a definite desire to have a
proper change and a responsible
leadership and I and I if things are
done correctly and ethically then I'm
certain that I will be the next FIFA
president